hello this is part c
of the proof complexity lectures in the
satisfiability boot camp at the simons
institute
um this talk will discuss
cdcl conflict-driven clause learning as
a
algorithm for satisfiability and
especially
from point of view of logic and its
connections to the resolution proof
system
we'll cover first dpll proof search then
cdcl conflict driven clause learning
proof search and the last part of the
talk will cover
proof logging where you log a complete
proof
resulting from a proof search run either
as a route proof
or more efficiently as a as a as a draft
proof
this talk will probably overlap somewhat
with
armand beerus talk the day before in the
boot camp
but most likely i'll be doing this from
a different point of view and this is
one of the core topics for
the special program of the simon's
institute so i think it's worth some
repetition
especially some from a different point
of view also i want to mention that
there's a survey article
by jacob nordstrom and myself that will
appear
shortly in the handbook of
satisfiability second edition
and a lot of the material from this talk
is based
more or less directly on what's in that
survey
um as an overview conflict-driven clause
learning solvers have been extremely
successful in solving very large
instances of satisfiability
routinely solving instances with
hundreds of thousands and even millions
of variables especially coming from
industrial
real world applications as compared to
com combinatorially based things
so this is really quite remarkable
because of the
fact that we know that resolution proofs
may need to be exponentially long
and the length of a proof is more or
less a lower bound on the length
of the number of steps taken by a cdcl
algorithm
because when cdcl solvers find an
instance of satisfiability to be
unsatisfiable
they mostly implicitly find a resolution
refutation and otherwise
they find to be satisfiable and
generally they then exhibit a satisfying
assignment
and it turns out to be a natural thing
to extend cdcl solvers to
include a so-called rat inferences that
i'll discuss near the end of this talk
and these make cdcl solvers in theory
as strong as extended resolution and i
stress the
in theory part because
in practice we don't know how to take
advantage of that full strength and
at the final bullet point uh early paper
by beam counts and
cyberwall outlined this connection
between cdl solver
cdcl solvers and resolution and it's
still a very
useful paper to read so i recommend that
in addition to our own survey
so as a very high level review sat
solvers
modern day sat solvers are built on four
principal components or at least many of
them are built on these four principal
components
they have dpl proof search which is a
kind of
depth first search for resolution rep
refutations where you iteratively set
variables to true false and backtrack as
needed
they use unit prop unit propagation
which corresponds to a proof system
called trivial resolution
to help set variables ahead of time
and guide the dpl search but also
underpins
clause learning and clause learning is a
method for inferring
new clauses that are consequences of
gamma or
can be assumed without any loss of
generality to be true
and then help prune the search space and
finally an unexpected component is
restarts
which interrupt a depth-first search and
start a totally new search
with not necessarily forgetting learned
clauses
now the fifth bullet point is many more
optimizations are there
i should mention variable selection
algorithms clause
forgetting algorithms um and
many others as well so but i'm going to
only mention
these four aspects of cdcl solvers and
probably
armand bira has covered many of these
other aspects for op
for optimization already
so this is a repeat of the slide from
part a of these lectures just defining
the system resolution
so if this is new to you i'll let you
pause the video and take a look at it
but pretty much i assume you know what
resolution is
uh we start with we're given as input a
set of clauses
namely representing a cnf formula the
goal is to either find
the goal for resolution is to refute
the cnf formula by showing cannot be
satisfied
and it's done by using the resolution
rule shown here
from x or c and not x or d we inverse c
or d and we use this iteratively to
return
to derive the empty clause and then
this is a sound and complete system for
refuting
cnf formulas for refuting sets of
clauses
so as a quick example of a resolution
refutation
here we have the initial clauses are
in square boxes uh or
rectangular boxes so like x or
y is an initial clause an axiom and it's
in a rectangular box here right and then
the inferred clauses are in oval boxes
so for instance
not z is inferred from the clauses y or
z bar and y bar or z bar by resolution
on y
and then from that x bar is inferred by
resolving x bar or z with z of z bar
and so forth deriving ultimately the
empty clause
and this can be written either as a dag
as drawn here or as a sequence
as written here on the side
this particular refutation shown here is
not regular
because there's a path namely start at
the empty clause go up to x
go up to x or y bar up to up to z bar
up to one of the axioms above it along
this particular path
we resolved here on the variable y
to derive x we resolved here
on the variable z to draw drive
x or y we resolved here again on the
variable y
to derive z bar so this path had two
places where we resolved on y
and thus it's not regular
from part a of this talk you recall that
any
unsatisfiable set of clauses has a
regular resolution refutation
but this particular one is not
so on the dpl search procedure
dpl stands for the authors of two papers
there was
davis putnam lodgment and loveland
there was a paper davis and putnam from
1960
and a paper by davis lodgman loveland
a couple years later and which outlined
together essentially what's known as the
dpl algorithm
so the input to the dpl algorithm is a
set of clauses
gamma and the goal is to either find a
satisfying assignment row that makes
every clause in gamma true
or to find a refutation of gamma
or at least to find evidence that
gamma's unsatisfiable
so the dpl algorithm works very
straightforwardly it performs a
depth-first search through the space of
partial truth assignments
it sets literals one at a time uh
and forming and maintains a partial
truth assignment row
when needed it backtracks to change the
values settings of literals and try
again
and when does it backtrack it backtracks
when some clause
is falsified by virtue of having all the
literals in it set false
so the algorithm is as follows we
initialize row to be the empty
assignment
and then we use the following recursive
procedure
so the recursive procedure does the
following first we'll check
if the current partial assignment row
falsifies some clause of gamma
if so we return false
this is not saying that the formula is
unsatisfiable
it's just saying that the partial
assignment's not working to satisfy
gamma
uh otherwise if rho satisfies gamma
then we're done row is set at least one
literal true in each clause
it's a satisfying assignment and we can
output row
as a satisfying assignment and terminate
otherwise and here's the
depth first search component of the
algorithm we pick some
currently unset literal x
we call that the decision literal we
extend row
by setting the literal x to be true
we call this recursive procedure
recursively
and if it returns it will return false
but if it returns at all
we update row now to set x to the
opposite value false
and we try calling the procedure again
recursively
now with row modified to set x false
if that also returns of course it
returns false then we just return
false if the top level call to dpll
returns false then the original formula
gamma
original set of clauses gamma was
unsatisfiable
and in this case it terminates saying
that
the formula is unsatisfiable otherwise
it terminates with a satisfying
assignment now in the case when it
terminates saying that gamma is
unsatisfiable
it's implicitly found a tree-like
regular
proof if you take the
tree of recursive calls in the dpll
algorithm that exactly mimics the form
of a tree like regular proof the
regularity is because we
once a literal has been set at row
we don't change its value unless we
backtrack and unset its value to the
opposite
and treelike is because the
depth first search algorithm is
implicitly tree-like
so here's an example of a tree-like
refutation arriving from a dpl
proof search this uses
the same initial clauses as shown in the
image on the previous
slide but uses a different refutation
because we need to have a regular
refutation to correspond to dpl proof
search the previous refutation was not
right regular so in this case the
the depth first reversal is shown on
this line
down here and it starts by setting x
true
then z false then backtracking then z
true
y faults and backtracking and so forth
and
let's see how this traverses the tree it
ends up being a
leftmost depth first traversal of the
proof tree
so we start at the root with the empty
clause
when we set x true we're implicitly
walking to this
clause here with contains not x so the
invariant is that the current set
variables
are falsifying the clause in the
refutation that we're traversing so
we've set x true
then we set z false and this falsifies
this gamma clause this clause from gamma
so we
having set that clause false we
backtrack and set
z true and now we're at the clause z bar
and this is
also set false by the current assignment
which sets z true
we in this traversal we then set y false
and we end up falsifying this input
clause
so we backtrack by setting y true we
falsify this
input clause now we backtrack
all the way back to the
the root and set x false
so we're at this point in the traversal
and we're at this node
in the in the tree in the proof tree we
continue like this
until we backtrack completely out of the
tree having failed to find
a satisfying assignment each attempt of
the
traversing the tree towards the leaves
resulted in a falsified
input clause from gamma
so you can check that this actually
works as a one-to-one correspondence
between
dpl proof search and tree-like
regular refutations
one thing to notice here is there's some
efficiencies in the dpl approved search
it's not literally trying all possible
truth assignments
so it has a chance of running much
faster than exponential time in some
cases
because you do not need to set all the
variables on all the panels the depth
first traversal in fact
this happened already at the very first
path we set
x true and z false and then we did not
set the value of y
we had already backtracked so that way
there's truncation occurs once we set a
clause false
so now we're going to add the second
ingredient which is unit propagation
so here we suppose that c
is a for unit propagation let's describe
this first as a general principle
if c is a clause in gamma or in our
currently set of derived clauses
and if row the current truth assignment
has set
all but one of the literals in c false
then any satisfying assignment extending
row
must set the remaining literal and c
true
so we augment dpl with unit propagation
to take this into account
so the algorithm is the same as the dpl
algorithm
but whenever it's possible to do unit
propagations with the current
truth assignment the current partial
truth assignment row we do them
because those values are forced there's
no point in trying to set those values
to the opposite value and then
we'll show the algorithm on the next
slide but first just to mention
a connection to proof complexity we
define a unit refutation to be a
resolution refutation in which
each resolution inference has at least
one of the two hypotheses
of the inference is a unit clause a
clause with a single
literal and as a theorem gamma has a
unit
refutation if and only if unit
propagation
finds a contradiction from gamma
starting with row
the empty assignment so we get a
connection between
unit propagations and unit refutations
so continuing on to the definition of
dpl with unit propagation
we again have a recursive frequency we
start by
setting row to be the empty partial
assignment that sets
values to none of the variables and then
we recursively call this procedure
the first step saves a copy of row
as row zero this is for backtracking
purposes
we then extend row by unit propagation
for as long as possible
so in other words we update the partial
truth assignment
row by setting true any literal which
follows by unit propagation
and setting one literal by unit
propagation may trigger other ones
becoming
true by by unit propagation
once we're done with that we check
whether rho falsifies some clause of
gamma
and if so we return false and we're
backtracking
otherwise if rho fully satisfies every
clause in gamma by setting at least one
literal true in each clause
we output row as a satisfying assignment
and the process terminates completely
no backtracking involved otherwise
now we're back to how dpl works we pick
some literal x that has not been set
yet we call that the decision literal we
extend row to set x true we call this
procedure
recursively we
otherwise update road set x false and we
call the procedure recursively
if that fails we're completely
backtracking out here
we restore row back to the saved value
row 0
and we return false going back one level
in the dpl procedure
so we can also give a characterization
of learning
uh so we for this is gonna this will be
the logical foundations of clause
learning
so we say that a resolution derivation
of a clause d from gamma
is trivial if the following things hold
so the first is that it's an
input refutation so in other words
every resolution inference in the
refutation has at least one hypothesis
from a clause in gamma the clauses in
gamma are called
input clauses so we're saying that we as
we derive things we're always using at
least
one input from gamma as hypothesis
and the second condition is that it's
regular
okay so this is the definition of
trivial res resolution
it's not so clear why
you would want to work with trivial
resolution but the reason becomes much
clearer when you
get the following characterization of
trivial resolutions for this one we let
gamma be a set of clauses
and let c be clause uh x1 or
x2 or dot dot xn so c has
n literals in it and we let row be the
partial truth assignment satisfying the
x i's in c
and then the theorem is that the
following are equivalent
a there's a trivial derivation of c from
gamma
and b unit propagation starting with the
partial assignment rho
based on c the partial assignment rho
that falsified the literals in c
and the clauses in gamma
yields the empty clause falsified in
other words falsify sunclaws
in gamma so the unit propagation this
way can be done very quickly
unit propagation is essentially a linear
time
algorithm and we're very close to that
and can be done very quickly so that's
an advantage of unit propagation
we have a special notation for this
property we say that
gamma one implies c
with a so it's a turnstile for
derivation with a subscript one
and there's two terminologies that are
used in the literature the older one
is c is inferred by reverse unit
propagation
from gamma and the other one is that c
is an
asymmetric tautology okay
and the again to stress this property to
stress this condition the property
gamma one implies c that c is a reverse
unit propagation clause or an asymmetric
topology
can be checked in polynomial time in
fact essentially in linear time
so when we introduce clause learning
we're going to use this as the basic
tool for learning clauses we'll only
learn clauses that can be inferred in
this way
so now we can describe the cdcl
algorithm
so this is the core of you know
many or most of the modern successful
sat solvers of at least the general
purpose successful sat solvers
so we have the following new ideas
on top of the dpl with unit propagation
first of all
when we do unit propagation to
derive a conflict
we're we discover clauses that can be
learned or inferred
by trivial resolution these learn
clauses
are saved into gamma they become one of
the currently known clauses
and they can be used to help future
proof search
and in particular they help prune the
proof search uh
in effect reducing the need to
re-traverse the same area of the search
space over and over again
after backtracking one important feature
of this
is that learn clauses help compensate
for poor choices of decision literals
and other optimizations include things
like backtracking or back jumping
which allows backtracking past decision
literals
that did not participate in the clause
learning process thus
further avoiding the need to re-traverse
the same
search space over and over again
so here's the algorithm for
cdcl a very high level thing
the basic version there's many
refinements of course so
we have a new variable l which is the
decision level
so each time a variable is set as a
decision variable
or more generally inferred by by unit
propagation
we remember the level of which its
search that's the level at which it's
set
the first decision variable is set at
level zero the next one's set at level
one and so forth
we initialize by setting row to be the
empty partial assignment
and now we loop so some of this looks
like dpl with unit propagation and some
of it
is adding learning so we extend row by
unit propagation for as long as possible
if it satisfies gamma
we return row as a satisfying assignment
otherwise if it falsifies some clause in
clause of gamma
before we would just backtrack but now
we do some learning
um if we're falsifying a clause at level
0 we just return
unsatisfiable we're just saying that
without any assumptions about decision
variables
we've falsified some clause so if we
falsify things at level 0
it's unsatisfiable otherwise we learn
one or more clauses c and add them to
gamma
these clauses are learned by reverse
unit propagation or
trivial resolution
and they get added to the database of
clauses we choose a
back jumping level l prime less than the
current level
we unassign all literal set of levels
greater than l prime
and we set l to l prime and now we're
going to backtrack
if we don't else if we haven't falsified
any clause at the current point we just
traverse
deeper we pick some unset literal x this
is the decision literal
we extend row to set x true we increase
the level
l plus one and we continue with the next
iteration of the loop
so this is cdcl
so let's talk about the learning process
this was the new part of this
was the learning process optionally
learning one or more clauses
usually it's just one clause and usually
it's what's known as a uip clause or
first uip
clause unique implication point so
here's an example of a so-called
conflict graph
and first uip learning so
here we've got a decision literal x
written now with a square box
and here i've got the empty clause here
on the right hand side
and each place here let's see what this
graph means
we've got some gamma has the following
clauses that are written here
the first one is not x or not
a or z and that means the same as
x and a implies z and corresponding in
the conflict graph i have
an arrow from x to z and an arrow from a
to z
and the meaning of this is because the
incoming edges of
z come from x and a once x is set true
and a is set true
z follows by unit propagation the next
one for example is not x or not z
or y and that says that y follows in the
graph
from x and z by unit propagation
and then this pattern continues
throughout the whole graph
at the very end we have falsity follows
from
if t and v and w are set true we get a
contradiction
and here i've got the clause t bar or v
bar or w bar
and that gives us the contradiction x
is the top level decision literal the
one that was last set as a decision
literal
a b and c are drawn with dotted things
to mean they were set at lower decision
levels
and then z y t u v s w
were all derived at the same decision
level as x by
iterative use of unit propagation
and now this dashed line here
sometimes called a cut is
separating the empty clause
and some of the literals that were used
to derive it by unit propagation
from the rest of the literals and so if
you'll notice here we've got the
edges crossing the dashed line there's
one from c to w one from b
to w one from a to u
and then several from y to
s t u and v and so
what this tells us is that if we set y
true
a true be true and c true that's enough
to get the empty clause
by unit propagation or to get a
contradiction via
unit propagation and so this tells us
that it's
not possible to have all four of those
literals true
and thus we can learn the clause
not a or not b or not c or not y
they can't all be true one of them must
be false at least one of them must be
false
and so this is a possible learned clause
and it can be learned
as a reverse unit propagation clause
just following the pattern
in the graph up there
and this is called a first uip clause
because if you'll notice here this is
this particular dashed line this
particular cut
has the property that there's only one
literal y
at the top decision level that is in the
learned clause worst negations in the
learned clause so we're looking for this
sort of
bottleneck point where there's only one
clause at the top decision level and
from that everything else follows
the using using literals from lower
levels and it's the
first uip because it's the bottleneck
level that's closest
to the empty clause
other comment here is once we have
learned the clause a bar or b bar or c
bar or y bar
this clause becomes asserting in the
following sentence asserting means
if we backtrack by unsetting all the
literals at the top level
and we can backtrack as much as we want
as long as we don't unset
any of a b or c then
y-bar can now be inferred by unit
propagation
from the fact that a b and c are
set true in the current partial truth
assignment and so this
gen this gives y true
by unit propagation without another
decision
variable and this
can then in turn trigger further unit
propagation
before settling down and needing another
decision literal
so here's another example
this is with a different set of clauses
not the ones from the previous slide
so here we're doing a cdcl reputation of
the clauses shown
down here
here's our initial set of clauses gamma
and the algorithm is going down
the first column and then learning this
clause in the dark oval
down the second column but skipping the
dash boxes and learning this clause in
the dark oval
and then down this column and learning
the empty clause as it were thus getting
a contradiction
so the way it works is it first sets w
as of this
to the value false as a decision
variable so this w
is assigned 0 or false as a decision
variable
now once w set false we have the clause
not u or w and we use that to set u
to false by unit propagation now nothing
else follows by unit propagation
so we take x to be set as a decision
variable to zero
and then unit propagation gives y and
then a further unit propagation gives a
z
and then we have falsified a clause
namely the clause y bar or z bar so now
if you
choose the cut appropriately namely x is
the first uip
literal we can learn by unit prop by
reversing the propagation
the clause u or x so this clause is
added to
the database of clauses so now we
backtrack to uh unset the value of
x we don't need to backtrack all the way
though these things are shown in dashed
the dashes
around the w set to zero and the u set
of zero means we don't redo that work we
just save it
now because we just learned u or x and
that's an asserting clause
now x is set true by unit propagation
because u is false and we've learned the
clause u r x
further unit propagation gives z and
falsifies the clause
x bar or z so now x is again the first
uip as it turns out
so we learn the clause x bar now this
was set
at level zero so we can backtrack all
the way
unsetting also w
and we have that
x bar is set to zero by unit propagation
from the unit clause x bar
and then further unit propagation gives
you w
and and falsifies the clause u bar or w
bar and now uh
we get just directly by unit propagation
a derivation of the empty clause
so then to view this
cdcl proof search process as a proof
we just throw away
the stuff about how things were derived
and here is the corresponding
resolution refutation we have using
these three initial clauses on the left
we have a trivial derivation of
u or x now using the next two clauses
here in the middle in the rectangles we
have a trivial derivation of
x bar now using
these two learned clauses and two more
of the original clauses
we get a trivial derivation of the empty
clause
so what you're seeing here is we have a
sequence of
trivial resolution derivations that
the results are saved as learned clauses
from each resolution
each trivial resolution reputation and
eventually we derive the empty clause
so that was the overall description of
the cdcl algorithm and how it relates to
resolution proofs another important
ingredient
is a so-called restart so a restart
means backtracking
the cdcl proof search back to level 0
where no decision literals have been set
and but this can be maintaining learned
clauses
and it's perhaps surprising but restarts
are extremely effective
in the practical use of cdcl solvers i
should add i said maintaining the
learned clauses but in fact
another big strategy that's used is
forgetting learned clauses
because that makes the proof search
procedure faster
and it's a very nice theorem of peapod 3
swat darwish
and ed series speaks to thoroughly
building on earlier work of beam counts
several wall is that cdcl
plus restarts can piece emulate
resolution
uh there's a bit of a caveat to this
theorem so
that first of all cdcl plus restarts
must
make the correct choices to simulate
resolution there's no
no known guidance for the procedure to
follow
and the other is that
you really need to do a lot of restarts
for this to work well
so um even now it's true that cdcl
solvers work quite well with a lot of
restarts but it's not
clear that it works so well because of
this theorem
but nonetheless this means that cdcl
plus restarts is as powerful as
resolution
and conversely it's not hard to show
that back just more or less the
outline of the previous slides shows
that resolution
can piece simulate cdcl even with
restarts
so what this means here is if you're
given the description of a cdcl
algorithm how it's
done decision literals and unit
propagation learning
and restarts then resolution can be a
then a resolution refutation can be
extracted from that
description of the run of the cdcl
algorithm
an interesting question is what happens
if we don't allow restarts
and this is actually open
so whether cdcl without restarts can
simulate re resolution
there's a couple mathematical models for
this question
uh i should mention pool resolution by
ben gelder
and reg wrti by hofmann new hashtag
myself
these give models for how cdcl without
restarts
might work as proof systems
and a pool resolution refutation
is a resolution refutation that viewed
as a dag
admits a depth first regular traversal
the reg wrti has a more complicated
definition i won't go into
and so it's open for instance whether
either these systems
can simulate resolution
again there's a caveat here as well on
the definitions of pool resolution reg
wrti
is that cdcl solvers without restarts
can do things that are not permitted
by pool resolution or reg wrti so the
correspondence is not exact there either
so for the final part of the talk i want
to talk about the idea of extracting
resolution proofs from cdcl solvers
in a practical setting so cdcl solvers
are nowadays very complex very
complicated
things with lots of optimization
techniques and
they're not only hard to code and get
the code correct thank bugs
it's also hard to combine different
techniques
that don't subtle that don't interact in
subtle ways that can lead to unsound
reasoning so thus it's desirable to have
stat solvers output refutations that can
be verified
independently of the
sat solver code itself so the first
proposal along this lines was to
was to use a rock proof reverse unit
propagation
proof so an r and r u p proof is a
sequence
of clauses c one through c k and it's
supposed to be
it's applying a proof but it's really a
refutation of gamma
uh we start off with gamma 0 is just the
set
gamma and now we're going to add
successively c1 then c2 then c3 et
cetera forming
gamma 1 then gamma 2 then gamma 3. and
we want the property to be
that c the l plus first clause
added is a reverse unit propagation
consequence
of the previous clauses so in other
words gamma sub l one implies
c sub l plus 1 and then we want to end
up with the empty clause
so we can also add the deletion
inference to throw away clauses that
aren't needed
and this interestingly enough can
greatly improve the verification time
already
so this is a nice idea and it fits very
well with the
simplified version of the cdc algorithm
c dcl algorithm i described earlier in
the talk
but it doesn't correspond very well to
actual cdcl
algorithms with full optimizations so to
give just a couple examples of this
cdcl solvers also frequently infer
clauses that are
not implied by gamma a prime example
is the pure literal inference which is
if
a literal p appears only positively in
gamma
so but the negation of p does not appear
in any clause in gamma
then we can without loss of generality
set p true
and this is known as a pure little
inference but it doesn't mean
that p follows from gamma in any logical
sense so in particular
the unit class p is not a reverse unit
propagation consequence of gamma
the extension rule is a very powerful
rule as we know and it also
can be used in proofs so in particular
for a new variable x we can infer three
new clauses expressing that x is
equivalent to q
or and r there they're shown here
and this can be done without loss
of any soundness properties even though
these three clauses don't follow as
logical consequences of gamma
they can be inferred to say that they're
true without loss of generality
and this particular viewpoint was
articulated by rebola pardo
sudo and the key
property here is that when we infer new
clauses
we can add them to the database scan of
clauses
we don't want to change the condition of
whether the set of clauses is
satisfiable or unsatisfiable so this is
called equisatisfiability
we infer clauses that may not follow
logically but when added do not change
the satisfiability or the
unsatisfiability of the set of clauses
and there's a lot of ways to
do this kind of inference with aqua
satisfiability and one particular one
is what's known as a as a
rat inference so rat stands for
resolution asymmetric tautology
and so the
definition of rat clauses are the
following
we've got a set of clauses gamma
we want to infer a new clause c and c
will be
so-called rat with respect to gamma and
c has the form c prime or p so p
is a literal appearing in c and c prime
is the rest of c
we say that c is wrapped with respect to
p and gamma
if for every other clause not p
or d prime in gamma so every other
clause containing the negation of p
when we resolve c prime against this
clause we obtain
a clause c prime or d prime which is an
asymmetric tautology in that
this clause c one or d prime is one
implied
by gamma or it follows by trivial
resolution
and the rat inference allows adding to
gamma any clause that can be inferred
by a rat inference and this can be shown
to preserve satisfiability and also to
preserve
unsatisfiability now clearly it
preserves unsatisfiability if gamma is
unsatisfiable adding a new clause to it
is still unsatisfiable
for satisfiability we can prove this
theorem by looking at the first step of
the davis putnam procedure
the davis putnam procedure can pick any
literal let's let it be p
and resolve away all occurrences of p by
doing all possible
resolution inferences on p so when we've
added
c prime or p the
newly obtained clauses by resolution on
p
are the forms c prime or d which are
already
logical consequences of gamma so in this
way
it's safe to add c
that is safe to add c prime or p because
if we run the davis procedure for one
step
eliminating p we don't get anything new
and this includes for instance things
like
the extension rule can be done this way
so the drat proof traces or draft proof
logging system
is we have sequence of clauses
which update the current set of clauses
with two rules
there's rat inferences which introduce c
by
a rat inference and this by the way
includes resolution and hence
trivial resolution and hence
um learned clauses and
as described before we also allow the
deletion rule
to remove any clause c so
this system is sound in the sense of if
we're trying to
refute a set of clauses we won't go
wrong with this kind of
these kind of steps an interesting fact
is it often takes longer to verify
refutations than to generate them
and that's the reason for the presence
of deletion
by deleting clauses it makes this unit
propagation property
easier to verify because there's fewer
unit propagations to do if there's fewer
clauses in the database
so this has been quite successfully used
for to verify large refutations
a particularly noteworthy one in size
was reported widely in the popular press
as well
build as the world's largest math proof
which i think is about true
this was a pythagorean triples problem
which uh was carried out by hoyla
coleman and merrick on
parallel processing it generated a draft
proof size of
200 terabytes which was compressed by
all the way down to 14 terabytes and
then further special encoding down to 68
gigabytes i don't know the details all
that
the runtime for generating the draft
proof
was about two days 3 700 plus
cpu hours and the verification time was
about
16 000 cpu hours but the point here is
that we actually
they were actually able to verify the
proof and independently
of the run of the ccl algorithm
as i already mentioned the draft proof
system
can simulate extended resolution and the
same is true in the other direction as
well
namely extended resolution can piece
simulate the d
d-rat system so should just give the
proof idea for one direction
that the draft proof system p simulates
extended resolution except the three
clauses of an extension rule for
x if only if q and r which are shown
here
these can be introduced one at a time as
rat clauses
so x is new so if we introduce
x or r or x bar this is
trivially wrapped because there are no
clauses that contain x
we introduce q or x bar that's again
true trivially rat
and then when we introduce q bar or
r bar or x this is also wrapped because
the only way to resolve on x is against
these two just
introduced clauses and they give
tautologies
with q or q q q bar or
r or r bar contained in the clause
so thus drat since it simulates extended
resolutions a very powerful proof system
but it's open how to extend cdl solvers
to exploit this
full strength of d d rat namely how to
extend them to exploit
the full strength of extended resolution
that's the end of part c thank you very
much